gamespot's Game of the Year 2015 was the
witcher 3 wild hunt that's kind of all
y'all got here was that that was the
game of the year way you didn't get to
hear was all of the screaming and
conversations and throwing a feces all
of that stuff so we're going to get into
a little bit of that as sort of how we
got got into that or how we got around
to the witcher 3 and this but also this
is kind of more important what i want to
do is like this is granny had this idea
we're going to round up everyone else's
game of the year awards so we're going
to basically cast shade on all the other
websites hey that's [ __ ] that's
watch it or we agree and let's get into
our conversation I guess via some of the
other winners so GamesRadar picked met
like a solid five the phantom pain in
this game of the year it was that rocket
League in The Witcher was kind of this
like three way conversation that we had
forever at Peter that was your favorite
game of the year well yeah you gave a 10
out of 10 on gamespot this year was
fantastic four games with competence I
was one of them and yeah what did you
what did you think about the
conversation we had a bash like you
agree with GamesRadar that it was game
of the year what do you think of the
conversations that we had about with
Witcher and walk Utley gonna last though
I haven't read GamesRadar as
justification I think it's a phenomenal
game and you know one of the things
whenever I talk about before I start
talking about why I love it I always
have to preface like cut up cut people
off by saying I know there's problems
like I know there are times when quiet
is just unnecessary like her appearance
I know the second half of the game had
some pacing issues right and the story
maybe you felt truncated at parts but
for me you know the first thing was the
gameplay was just impeccable like
there's so many things happening at once
and once you really get in tune to the
controls it all happens so seamlessly
and you almost forget how intricate it
was to begin with but then when you look
back or you start to play other games
you're like why aren't I transitioning
from one position to another as smoothly
like how come I can't just quickly whip
something out or react to assist a
scenario so the game the the controls
were one aspect the visual presentation
both within cinematics and within the
game was astounding and that made it
really easy for me to just sort of find
myself you know in awe of what was
happening around me I
me and and quiet you know again for as
many problems as she has uh I don't want
to spoil anything for anyone hasn't
played it unless you guys are done oh no
don't don't don't watch don't spoil it
but get to like yeah I know you're good
yes she you're allowed to take
companions with you into the field and I
used her quite a bit cuz I liked her
abilities I thought they gave me a good
tactical advantage yeah and uh okay she
can't speak for one reason or another
and but one thing she can do is hum and
so you know you don't always see her
when she's with you versus like d dog
who's next to you right she could be off
somewhere but you have radio
communications and when she's trying to
tell you that she's ready to do
something she starts to hum this little
tune in her ear and I never like it's
easy to feel alone in Metal Gear even if
you've got you know your dog with you
because it's an animal that's really not
that smart yeah like you can kind of
tell what to do and it's cute but it's
really you can only rely on your side
they watch the basically a one-man army
yeah but not with quiet with quiet
you're a two-man army and you know I I I
felt really attached to her and the way
that the game sort of manipulated that
feeling of attachment right it can't
remember a game that I've ever played
that made me wrestle with so many
feelings you know from one character
like that I'm not like but it wasn't
even like a scripted part of the story
minute right it's scripted but optional
and the sort of things that happen and
it all has to do with how attached to
her you are yes I how much yeah yeah
yeahs it yeah that's not get into the
anymore but doctor I was kind of like
the crux of the last load the the
biggest the most frustrating part of the
game of your conversation was between
these kind of three games and where they
sawed and had worked because like that
experience that you had I didn't have
because not alone that I not use Herrera
and I also only completed the first half
of that game which was like 70 hours
whatever but like I didn't so I didn't
even get to pass that point you hadn't
completed the witcher 3 right so all the
things we were talking about was like
these were both games a word like a
hundred twenty hours long we had played
all these other games and then like
rocket League is there's like trying to
compare rocket league with metal casado
to the witcher is a [ __ ] nightmare
because it's like it's a five minute
game
ana repeats it just for some people it
really works it works for Rock Paper
Shotgun dates they gave it their they
did loads of weird gave the year kind of
bits and bobs all over place they said
it was the their favorite overall game
of the year and yeah you you cited on
that 1i you till you still think was
best gaming came in last year yeah and I
[ __ ] love metal gear solid I played a
lot of it on PC and you love to Witcher
oh I love love the winter if I'm we're
gonna give like love love love I new
rating system but yes like Metal Gear
was awesome and there's so many systems
at play and everybody just goes on about
that and it's true did you finish it I
did not finish it damn it but like I got
only thing this soap I know I know but
like more than even what I was talking
about earlier and we had the same
problem I just resetting another
especially like that coming out a tease
but tech like higher tech me up now but
like cold war and Soviet nine paid play
that game enchanting world oh yes well
all that Simon dog says together again
oh well yeah yeah and like it's so
strong the movement and the stealth and
then all the abilities like you're
saying don't get me wrong like that was
phenomenal achievement and then you go
to like Witcher right and I'm such a
huge washer frame fanboy and like that
game delivered on every little thing you
would ever want out of open world which
I get the war it's also subject to those
are like it's all anticipation and what
you want and rocket league is like a
game you don't even know anything about
and but like just the characters and
everything in The Witcher like that's
basically all the witcher can stand or i
think because like the game plays all
right ran the systems are kind of tank
and inventories jake and the crafting
whatever its deep but like do you really
want to but it definitely hang your hat
on yeah it has more wrinkles in malguri
oh yeah for sure um but like it's so
strong like as a narrative experience
and like as a game fan and as like
artists you know whatever like we love
like I love that [ __ ] oh yeah that's
when I think about game of the year it's
like aspiring to greatness yay what game
got there the best that's kind of a bit
so what is that rightly so so this
transitions into that right so it's like
I think Metal Gear was like systems the
best game Witcher was like art yeah the
best game but then it's like okay
and then I don't know a rocket League
consumed my [ __ ] life like fun it's
it became a sport it's intoxicating and
yeah and I think the reason that I have
to say it's my personal gaming there why
I think we should have pushed it for
game in the air was it's gonna stand
longer in my life than a either those
game right uh not just like play time
wise but just length of time wise and
when you think back of like the games
you love ya and like 10 years from now
you'll click that one out yeah like so
when when I have to rank my personal
games of all time yeah rocket leaves on
that list whereas like Metal Gear kind
of falls down and so does Witcher
because like I cuz it's like a race
irrational love of games like in its
Skyrim Max Payne but but it is funny
thing about that is that like what
that's the problem we have is because by
the time we got to those last three no
purchase so personal yeah like and like
and how do you say my personal feeling
of this game is more than you because I
guess the problem we have is that you
definitely love Meleager solid perhaps
more than the median level but there was
this force for rocket League because
there was so many people right so we
just had to like wait to talk between a
bit like the conversations were long
because it was like helmet that those
you know popular vote matter against
consensus folks right so that's the
thing though is that we ran like a staff
wide popular vote and the numbers were
very different for the top three mmm
like Metal Gear had way more support and
until we started to whittle things down
and and and you'll have these open
discussions and an impassioned speech
can change people change mine yeah
compassion one way or another I think
really alter people's opinions yeah I
think it's easy to argue logically for
rocket League as well like as upset like
all the games you can argue logically
but like as a video game like it's it is
a [ __ ] video game like you're playing
it you're interacting what you're
getting better you're playing with your
team it's like it's the culmination of
all this modern stuff like good
matchmaking like it was free so
everybody there's a huge pool of players
like you get better and good online
communications like easy just like the
journey style right the problem I
problem take a shot like it's you know
you just yeah it just becomes and this
stupid thing I wrote that I'm gonna
share and it's so far up my own blood
who cares it was like so Witcher it's a
dark place so this is just comparing
Witcher and partly Witcher the art is
the writing the characterization acting
the storytelling the pacing everything
that goes into that but like the the
poetry in rocket League is actually you
doing it on the field where you leave
your mark on the field joga bonito baby
Google you're talking about the
beautiful game to me that's more
powerful you know in a way right yeah
like okay but so why is that why is that
different from something like fifa and
i'm not saying okay get it isn't good
question I just but that I think people
would probably benefit by figuring why
Danny obviously like broke that down
really well we're second 50 are playing
as a team that those were the quick
elevator pitch of that is like in fief
you're playing as a team and in rocket
League you're playing as a foot you're
like you're your direction over the ball
is is it's like it's a bad where you hit
that ball and where it goes nosh the
plays you're making so it's kind of like
it's like a macro micro kind of thing
and for me like rocket League I've said
at lunch times last year was like who is
the best soccer game best football game
I've ever played because it felt more
like when I was I like a play football
my whole life I felt more like an uneven
like the weirdest thing is like I played
on goal like from my whole life like at
various like levels like I've played for
like 20 years I guess and I've had times
where I've like as a goalkeeper
predominantly so I've had times where
I've run across the goal and like
fingertip like anticipated this ball I
think it's gonna go there they hit it I
kinda barely saved it and I still
remember those moments and like I have
done that in rocket League and it's felt
the same sure epsilon that's like really
so bad but anyway so that's kind of
stuffs a week on into so it's
interesting to look at some of the other
winners on different websites the
Guardian gave for instance blood-borne
was one that blood-borne fans like the
people who want blob Ormsby came at a
year are so sure that it's game of the
year we had a lot of people saying like
it's fine you think that blow born is
the best game that came out this year or
PS or sorry I'm the Guardian thought
that as well what do you think about
that Peter it's like game yeah I know
it's a it's one of those games that I
wish I was better at because I didn't
get that it wasn't able to finish it and
partially that was due to time because i
wasn't able to get better but that game
has amazing atmosphere and it has really
really good mechanics that are difficult
but fair
I think it has a lot of things going for
it what I think was missing from me when
when listening other people talk about
it is that it was solid but not special
right and I'm not sure why maybe that's
because we have dark souls and that was
sort of a semi blueprint for for
blood-borne but at the same time like
I'm not going to sit here and say it's
not an amazing game that doesn't deserve
recognition and if they had the best
experience with it and kudos to them
yeah that's that's what they believe it
is a little bit of an outlier in terms
of the median that should not be denied
that's not like this is the interesting
thing about game of the years is that
like nobody's wrong yeah which is I Jan
for instance the imagine games network
they picked saying and we did witcher 3
wild hunt and i guess the one that is
the one we're leading up to because it's
it's the one in which people are saying
like no that's wrong and i think there's
a lot of issues discussion have about
this which is that although polygon gave
would witcher the best open-world game
their game of the year eventually went
to her story which is a game i think we
hadn't i think was like 18th or so on
are so we did recognize it as a great
game it won a bunch of words the game
awards it's kind of in a lot of people's
top tens around there and but it is kind
of interesting to think that either the
consensus vote or the popular vote put a
game that was so far down the list of so
many people's a game of the year right
at the top Peter what do you think about
that that the it kind of does speak to
the people who work a polygon right it
does I could make sense it's like oh
okay yeah of course that's the game the
polygon will probably go for right um
yeah but I don't know that I want to
like whittle it down to just the
identity of polygons or just sort of
like what we know who works there and
what they like right but you know like
people we're so concentrated in our
discussions because we work in an office
together like the games that we play
like rocket League that we fall in love
with you know that sort of it starts to
fold in on itself and become you know
this deeper thing and so who knows maybe
the right mix of people played it there
and got enough people's ears and then
they played it and their discussions
around it were more impassioned cuz in
the office here you know when we started
playing that game it was like oh her
stories actually pretty interesting you
know like and then we kind of like
dabbled in talking about certain things
but I also don't think enough people
played it and I don't think we
has long enough discussions about what
happened in that game and why it worked
and I think maybe if we did and this
probably applies to other games as well
it may have been higher on our list
probably wouldn't been top 10 though
right are these number number one no I I
don't think I don't think so not based
on the personalities we have here and
again i hate to sort of just like put
people into a corner at polygon or any
website and say well of course they
chose that but but you know i mean there
is this perception that they are very
socially focused and they're into
experimental stuff and you know whatever
that's good that's kind of an
interesting thing actually that we kind
of touched on a lot of times in our
conversations here is that like games
press loves something new like we
probably appreciate the new more than
most like the median gamer because we're
interacting with so many games all the
time so when there's something new it
kind of like sparks a joy in us because
we're used to playing some of these so
many things so i wonder if there's
something because the public reaction to
some like this is either people saying
oh okay that's great your champion
anytime a different type of game then
the other people would say like oh it's
an F mvgame and you're just being
contrarian for the sake of us because
like you want to look different and no
one's going to pick our story this year
so if what we're talking about is
actually that this is just something
that they really liked is it to be
criticized or good like how do you feel
about the idea that the games press
should represent gamers and not tell it
should or like where does it represent
gamers and where it is represented
people writing and intervene I music
because that's I feel like that's how
people look at our game of the year as
well they go like pick the right one
because you're speaking for us you know
me anyone at home who thinks that that
should be the case the next time you're
talking to your friends about games talk
about the games that you think your
sister would like I mean right diculous
notion like why should i why should I
have to change who I am like if I'm in
this position in my position is talk
about the games I care about the way I
want to know where the way that I want
to talk about them that's my prerogative
that's all I care about games are very
personal they're not this thing that is
to be sort of like mixed together and
then like flopped on a plane here you go
that this is kaylee's a reader can I
have some more no yeah it's yeah I mean
is that there's the problem we face in
comments sections right would be right
people get very personal but they
realize because they think we're doing a
disservice because they think it's what
the average person wants and the app
there is no average person unless unless
you're trying to go for like which game
sells the most but that comes down to
some hey guess what how many people had
call of duty on like if you're like the
next layer exactly the next layer of
that is because we can say oh like then
if the polygons are like let's just say
they're being unlike the you know
they're representing one percent agree
and like we're representing more people
because we picked the weight like
[ __ ] Mahan like destiny right like
the taken King didn't qualify but that
that's what people were playing people
whooping dota the league of legends yes
call of duty that's a good question that
I want to like pause it right yeah go
for it what if cuz we do game of the
year and because we cuz it's fun i guess
and gets traffic yeah but like I would
enjoy the process I yeah it's like super
fun it's a good way to like actually
talk about yeah kind of way she didn't
have as much import at Stuart that's the
only thing I don't like but like what if
we had a every year there was an
adjustment to like the best game ever
right oh it's like it's like a top 200
list yet we just change 100 seems like a
lot so high 52 still at the top oh yeah
it's like five like what are the five
best games ever and it's like every year
you like reevaluate it and it's like
counter-strike is still number one yeah
like half-life and it's like so how do
you be better than that like DotA's up
there right like and then what else I'm
Peters like shaking his head like that
yes is that doesn't that's like as this
year's problem yeah x 100 exactly if I
had my way we would all right reviews
without scores and just leave it at that
right oh yeah these top 10 lists we
wouldn't do olean it you know I think I
think it can do value like the
conversations around games really easily
and ranking games it just becomes like a
crap not a crapshoot but it becomes a
very difficult process to actually be
sound and reasonable right you'll easily
quantify this is better than that yeah
at a certain stage you just say so cuz
we are like hypocritical by nature so
it's like you're gonna change your minds
and contradict and it's like so
subjective and it's so [ __ ] out there
people are playing loads of
counter-strike right now yeah they
weren't maybe 10 years ago I don't that
gone on map is just blowing up
yeah and so it's like what what made
that having like League of Legends to
popular belief I can't play it you know
I mean it's crazy it seemed like last
year felt like a year war was so
difficult like any one of these games
you could say is like easily like
somebody's and not even just somebody's
a young person's but lots of people's
favorite geared game of your blood war
which or her story rocket League
Malachor solids like it's not hard for
me to say odds my number one anything
bad that it's like [ __ ] I don't what
between five and six like yeah if I move
them to that look right did I like city
skylines more than Mario maker it wish
there was like an academy you she had
more no life so that you didn't have
yeah well that's the problem ok yeah so
final point on this I guess is like okay
the endgame of this is that we end up
having something like the Oscars right
hey it's like we don't look at the game
awards it's like that should be all and
end all and different various people
look towards if me like some people look
towards like okay I want to know what
like total biscuits favorite game of the
Earth's all I want to know what gamespot
says I want to know what like my
favorite twitch streamer is with like
different people the different layers of
import I don't think we want some like
one big one bastion of that because the
Oscars feel like to get it wrong every
year or like right or they try and go
for that popular vote yea or somewhere
between the popular vote and the Arctic
artistic vote in the kind of but Birdman
is the her story well yeah Birdman is
like a bird man as a game made for film
critics yeah and you could say her
stories again they're probably appeals
to Game Critics more than it does to you
know Joe call a duty if that's the
median gamer so like I don't know I just
want to recognize things for the special
achievements like right yeah I the farm
aid gamespot but like i just think it's
it's what we're doing you know it
doesn't really serve a really strong
discussion about games it just distracts
and makes us argue again yeah try to say
yeah this is the best of the worst
whatever we should just have like peter
brown game of the year and that's it we
don't say anybody else like you choose
one person every year and that's their
year like [ __ ] Hunger Games yeah we
have like we have like a [ __ ] gauntlet
you have to go no yeah yeah we volunteer
Peter as tribute and then we get all the
other I mean we basically as a pax yeah
I mean all the other games press to pick
and then who wins that gets a figure
that
right we cry baby and II Peter thanks so
much for coming on here and figure
engage game 4 30 2016 with me appreciate
it and let us know what you think it was
game with your 2015 which publication
you side with also let us know like what
do you think of the idea that anyone can
pick any game for Game of the Year do
you think there's importance assigned to
game of the year do you have an
appreciation for the fact that this
stuff is so subjective and you know
ultimately you shouldn't really push
your opinion against someone else's
opinion or is that something you enjoy
let us know in the comments below